du fromage on en mange beaucoup
l'accord économique de 2017
entre le canada et l'union européenne
permet maintenant d'importer seize mille
tonnes de fromage européenne de plus par
année sur cinq un peu plus de nouveaux
fromages européens qu'ils sont rentrés
mais ça va se faire de façon progressive
jusqu'en 2022 et mentale gouda bris des
fromages industriels et semi industriel
peut maintenant entrer en grande
quantité au pays
l'industrie et les fromages et sont
inquiets mais quel impact cela aura-t-il
pour les consommateurs c'est sûr qu'à
long terme il va plus de compétition ce
marché de la compétition je crois doit
être vraiment nouveau des produits
industriels
soyez pas inquiets les fromages
québécois ont toujours une grande place
dans nos magasins pour le moment ces
nouveaux permis l'importation n'ont pas
entraîné de variations de prix des
fromages consommateurs si vous
recherchez un gain sur le ps qui voit
les chercher un gain sur l'offre c'est
ce qui se perd dans les relais pas
d'augmentation de prix il ya un
environnement qui pourrait
potentiellement y amener des baisses de
prix qui pourrait potentiellement y
amener un petit peu plus de produits sa
table christian or présentement c'est
des grandes entreprises et les moyens de
l'entreprise qui vont être plus touchés
et parce que le met les moyens
on a des entreprises sont spécialisées
dans les boudoirs fromagerie bergeron
qui fait un excellent produit mais c'est
sa spécialité est fixé ce que lui ses
importations lendemain dans une
situation précaire
fo qui développe de façon intensive une
marque forte de façon intensive des
produits que consommateur d'eau
reconnaît le nouveau de la petite
entreprise je pense qu'à s'en sort bien
parce qu'elle a su développer des
produits niche est très différenciée que
le consommateur veut à la fromagerie au
gré des shows on se consacre à faire des
produits distinctifs par amour du
fromage ya juste au québec qu'on a le
droit de faire ce type de fromage au
lait cru avec un permis spécial
le comble en lauréat de prix caseus 2018
fait partie de ces fromages artisanaux
de petites entreprises pour lesquelles
on crée moins comme ça voyage moins bien
on peut se dire que la conversion reste
est moins forte avec magie européen qui
pourrait laisser certains c'est certain
nous on fait des fromages au lait cru
fermier bio alors on est vraiment dans
un secteur très pointu mais ceci dit
écoutez dans les fromages qui m'ont
enlevé il ya des très très bon fromage
fait un peu peur je pense qu'on peut pas
s'asseoir sur nos lauriers puis pas
s'inquiéter de ce qui peut arriver le de
l'europe
si les plus petits au moins à craindre
de leur côté les consommateurs ne
peuvent s'attendre à une baisse de prix
des fromages fins on peut pas baisser
nos prix mais je ne sais pas quand je
peux pas arriver à baisser les prix moi
j'essaie de d'être le plus équitable
possible
on veut bien payer nos employés on a
décompté payer aussi je peux progresser
mépris
mais il faut comparer des pommes avec
des pommes les conditions sont pas les
mêmes en europe
c'est que l'élève en europe est moins
cher que le lait canadien donc c'est
certain que
uno du coup du coût du produit une
différence déjà la tis a exclu toute
sorte des subventions possibles et
imaginables peut exister en europe le
pour soutenir les producteurs les
transformateurs
nous ne voulons pas que les fromages
québec baisse leurs cris nous voulons
que les fromagers du québec gardent leur
qualité égale aux goûts et saveurs et
c'est très important pour notre
consommateur on veut pas descendre la
qualité du produit en décembre
ce n'est pas le critère d'achat chez iga
pour le moment pas de changements dans
l'offre
on trouve toujours plus de 230 fromages
québécois du goût et la saveur
c'est le premier critère que le
consommateur recherche et honnêtement le
fromage et du québec ont des goûts et
des saveurs incomparables l'importation
répondre à une demande
neuf qui n'existe pas par exemple le
parmesan nous n'avons pas une offre
suffisante de parmesan au québec il y en
a très peu présente
honnêtement il faut aller chercher de
l'importation service irs je ne sais pas
content pour le consommateur quelles
vont être les specs gagne de tso c'est
ce qui se perdent
gagnon aussi sur la fraîcheur 6
importations permettent aux détaillants
des souris un inventaire régulier et de
transiger sans intermédiaire auprès du
producteur
on a décidé d'investir dans
l'importation du brie de meaux par avion
première fraîcheur et aussi on a demandé
aux producteurs de
de notre brimo de d'affiner le fromage à
point cancon leur soit aux deux semaines
on a deux semaines pour le
commercialiser à 20 lits est importé par
bateau
trois semaines de transport donc fallait
le commander très très jeune pour
l'instant donc les fromages fins d'ici
reste dans la course
ici deux fois match elle les poulies
saint-pierre fermi d'appellation
d'origine contrôlée le jack le chevry de
saint flavien près de québec
est ce qu'ils sont capables de
compétitionner en prie je vous dirais
que c'est semblable fait semblant pour
créer vos plateaux de fromages à noël
cette année pas de changements notables
on pourra encore profiter du meilleur
des deux mondes deux fromages à pâte
molle le bring que je vous parlais tout
à l'heure
donc une part très fondante on voit le
plus de coeur donc est vraiment un point
est ici un partenariat avec une
fromagerie le calme du lac-saint-jean le
tremblay qui est un fromage au lait non
pasteurisé très très bon très goûtu le
consommateur à long terme va payer moins
cher les fromages et on espère qu'ils
vont manger davantage
[Musique]